one of the things I noticed about the
new atheists is that they aren't all but
a lot of them are kind of white
Christian men and and I think that as a
Jew an atheist Jew there are things
about the religion even though I don't
believe it that are impossible to
disentangle from my identity and I think
it was I think it's impossible for
someone like Richard Dawkins to sort of
understand that I think it's impossible
in a way for Richard Dawkins uh to
understand why when he is dissing Islam
for example that feels to a Muslim like
an attack on their identity in a way
that it might also do to a Christian but
not in quite the same way because within
the society that Dawkins exists
Christians are not a persecuted minority
and Jews As A persecuted minority will
always feel
that